i'm so excited to announce that out of  all the incredible stories that we've  heard the women we featured the women we  couldn't feature  the remarkable woman just one from las  vegas  is sitting right next to me and that is  trudy park killman  congratulations  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  congratulations  we tried so hard to keep this as a  surprise i can tell you're surprised  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  congratulations trudy on being named our  remarkable woman for las vegas  we know you spend a lot of time trying  to raise money for your charity and we  think this should help out with your  cause  on behalf of klas tv8 and nexstar media  group we are presenting your charity  with a check for one thousand dollars  thank you so much for the amazing work  you're doing  in our community  [Music]  you